welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your insider on
the outsider and this episode were
breaking down the fifth entry in the
season
HBO must have got spooked by Super Bowl
Sunday so they've dropped the episode
early and throughout this video we're
gonna be going through the new entry and
what happens in it there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want
anything potentially ruined it then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
we will be talking about certain
elements of the book as per usual so if
you don't want anything spoiled about
the future of the show then it's time to
leave the video if you're still here I
just want to give a huge thank you for
sticking around now let's get into our
breakdown of the outsider episode five
opens in the midst of a shootout between
a lone gunman and the police similar to
Jack we can see on the back of his neck
that he has a huge rash we cut to the
character three days prior and see him
holed up in a home that has child killer
written in graffiti on the outside it
turns out that this is Heath Hofstede
his household the apparent child killer
who we saw died in prison in Episode
three we see the character making hits
bed and this act of remorse is purely
driven by guilt it's revealed that he
was working with the outsider was
complicit in the killing of the children
and helped the frame heat for the crimes
after his airtight alibi the outsider
needs an accomplice in order to operate
and we learn that this was his at the
previous town as we know the outsider is
manipulating Jack currently and
completely warping his mind by
tormenting him this has sent him off the
deep end and he started slowly
descending into madness if he'd been
keeping up-to-date with the recap so far
then you'll know that we've discussed
how the outsider is similar to a vampire
and in Jack he has found his Jonathan
Harker in Bram Stoker's Dracula Harker
ended up falling under a sort of spell
from the titular character and this
servitude that he fell into you saw him
eating bugs and almost worshipping
Dracula as a deity here we see Jack
following a similar story teen and
building a home for the character in the
woods like Harker he soft turns against
his master but the way that he operates
gives us a good idea of how the outside
it is to because of this we now have a
pattern of behavior for the antagonist
of
show and from the way that the outsider
works we can tell it tends to show up to
a town take blood from a local through
this blood change its DNA to match their
appearance feed upon a child frame the
person are now imitating and then lie
low in the area feeding upon the grief
of the families that are caught up in
the tragedy and then chooses a new
target and rinse and repeats the process
like I do with these videos every week
clearly the creature needs someone in
order to help it gain supplies build a
nest and operate at its current location
and Jack has very much taken this
position infancy
Jack seems crazy at the beginning of the
episode but pretty well-balanced later
on and yeah we're just gonna get into
why this isn't really Jack after Jess's
dreams we did guess that when she was
describing how the second time at the
outsider showed up he was transforming
into the copper due to his apparent
better physique though we did bounce
back and forth on this in the last video
as it was revealed that Maitland cut the
bouncer at the strip club as well here
we do know that there are two different
versions of Jack due to the length of
his sideburns throughout the episode at
the beginning when he's going crazy
there long and then when we see him
later they're short and it's a very nice
minor detail to show the difference
between the two that doesn't mean that
al cuoco isn't the bouncer or manager or
whatever he works says and clearly
something is going on with him we are
yet to see how this plays out but
perhaps if Jack bolts he will become the
next one that the titular character uses
we also learned that not only can the
outside of manifests physically but it
can also take on an ethereal form and
attack people spiritually the real jack
is clearly becoming sick of the
outsiders demands and he may decide to
fight back similar to the man from the
introduction aware that Anderson is hot
on the trail while Coco did pass a
message on through Jessa to back off the
case but this has fallen on deaf ears
and now we see the outside as stalking
missus Anderson is it is it just me or
does he look like he's waiting to grab a
microphone and say F oh right in the
[ __ ] anyway I digress Anderson clearly
hasn't backed off and through Holly he's
built up a pattern of how the character
travels from town to town operating
after five weeks of waiting and
theorizing this episode really starts to
pull everything together and I finally
feel like I can openly talk about what
the plot is and how things may happen
going forward the outside of is it's
jeannie and as in the case with Jessa it
appears at night and passes on a message
about how Ralph will die if he doesn't
drop the investigation he threatens to
kill her to you and we get way more into
the side of the outsider that he's a
shadow that stalks his victims
this dreamlike trance that Jeannie was
in makes her initially question whether
it was real or not but due to the cuts
and a feet from standing on broken glass
we know that it was she later tries to
convince Ralph to drop it but he refuses
to as we know he only believes in things
with rational explanations and this is
sort of a gift and a curse for the
character as the investigation goes on
Jeannie draws a picture of the outsider
after seeing his face and this lines up
with the boy from the last episode who
also had a police sketch made in Holly's
world she's at a bar questioning the
bartender about who the boogey man was
for her as a child like the ending of
last week's episode we learned that the
outsider has existed for centuries and
our modern myths and legends have
evolved from tales of it the now aptly
named tear drinker is theorized at
hanging around at cemeteries due to the
fact that families will often visit
there and grieve as we know similar to
penny wise the outsider feeds off a
certain emotion but where penny wise
feeds on fear
the outsider feeds on grief they also
operate both psychically in ways that
align with one another in the Stephen
King book it
Pennywise was able to carry out so many
child murders undetected because it used
to almost hypnotically convinced the
adults in the town of Derry to be
nonchalant towards missing children this
is a phenomenal chapter in the work that
centers around the investigation of
Adrienne melon's death and how though
witnesses saw the clown at the scene
they know this won't be believed in
court and thus it's dropped from all
proceedings the outsider clearly works
like this - trying to intimidate those
who are close to finding out what's
going on into leaving the cases well
alone for me it sort of works like a
metaphor for how society and the police
work in general in recent years we've
heard several cases of child abuse
carried out by celebrities and people in
positions of power that were never
really investigated probably by police
because they were either corrupt or
fearful for their lives in Korea's
similar the outsider because of this
these predators were able to carry on
like this for so long and they've had a
couple of people ask why it's only now
that the creature has even been close to
being caught this episode lets us know
that that probably isn't the case and
like anderson the villain must have
intimidated them into sweeping it under
the rug Hawley visits the cemetery in
which the Williams were buried and we
see what could have been its hideout
during its time in the area Hawley comes
across the man from the introduction
that made Heath spared and also wound up
dead he tells Holly about how the
outsider screwed Heath and himself over
she also instructs Anderson to go to the
cemetery where teri is buried and they
realized that the barn is within walking
distance and we now know that this is
where it resided a Collins's baby shower
Anderson sees Jack and he goes off on
one this is actually the outsider and as
I mentioned earlier we can tell that it
is due to the length of his sideburns he
refuses to hold the baby probably
because it looks tasty and he storms out
the party that night Collins has a dream
that someone has come into a home and
taken a baby and it is possible that the
outsider also didn't want to hold the
child because he wants to frame jack for
its death should that happen dreams have
haunted several characters throughout
the season however that doesn't mean
that they're all bad anderson too has
his own dream which offers a message of
hope as we know if evil forces exist in
the world
then good must - an Aniston's visitor
comes in the form of his son he tells
his father that he needs to let him go
as we know al cuoco feeds on grief and
robbing the character of the Andersons
grief of their son will definitely
starve it in some ways in the book the
child was alive and was only away a camp
so I'm glad they changed it up for the
show
as it makes a lot more sense here and
ties in with the overall themes it's one
of the most touching moments of the
season so far
and it reminds us that if there is evil
there is also good Al cuoco visits
Anderson as jack in apologizes about the
party and asks to be granted access to
the inside of the investig--
so yeah once more this isn't Jack being
a nice guy he's probably still in the
woods screaming at trees we then cut to
the other outside his accomplice and see
how he ended up dead at the beginning of
the episode it turns out that he had a
man held at gunpoint with an unloaded
weapon and he just wanted to be murdered
we don't know all of the ins and outs of
his psychology but due to the bed-making
and his comments at the graveyard he was
clearly filled with regret over the
entire incident and just didn't want to
live anymore Episode five closes with an
essence vision of his son and we cut two
credits knowing that Ralph won't be
providing the creature with any more
grief to feed upon now obviously I loved
hear your thoughts on the episode and
what you've thought of the season so far
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please give it a
thumbs up and make sure you check out
our full breakdown of the season which
is gonna be linked in the playlist at
the end if you want to watch a different
breakdown and please check out our
ending explain recap on the new Netflix
season the stranger if you'd like to
support the channel from as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below your access to content
early and can also suggest video topics
and breakdowns we massively appreciate
you it and it goes a long way to helping
videos like this get made you want to
come chat to us after the show either
follow us at Definition whitey or the
discord link in the description below
every month we give away free movies to
people who are subscribed to the channel
and this month you can win dr. sleep and
all you have to do is comment on a video
and make sure you sub with notifications
on the more videos you comment on the
more you have a chance of winning so
make sure you get involved the winners
gonna be chosen at random on the 15th of
February it's the best of luck to
everyone he takes part
this is the channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]